i'll i'll bug you about it later okay
sure
um yeah i just i don't have the
recording thing uh configured correctly
but anyway okay
right perfect um
all right uh hopefully you guys can see
my screen please complain at me if you
can't
um yeah so uh obviously yesterday we
went through
um a kind of a quick derivation of how
causal invariance leads to
uh kind of effectively conformal
invariants that you know causing the
variance guarantees that
uh in the because the causal network is
always unique for these warfare model
systems that the
time ordering of events is always uh
preserved you know under parameterized
change of foliation
uh even when the ordering of space like
separated events is not and how we you
know how we can make a correspondence
between that
and things like the symmetry that we
know in ordinary physics
um but i also mentioned that you know
causal invariance is a much stronger
property than that
it gives you not just lorent symmetry
but also punkari symmetry and local
laurent symmetry
and there were a couple of sort of
mathematical subtleties that i somewhat
glossed over in in the last lecture that
you may have noticed
um so one of them that i tried to point
out was that the our definition of the
norm this multi-wave and koski norm
which i introduced essentially for
pedagogical purposes
uh is very very naive and in fact
there's a much more sort of sensible
norm
uh a much more sensible metric that we
can define on these on these hypergraphs
and on these causal networks
but to do that requires a bit of
additional kind of machinery and that's
what i want to talk
about today and the other thing was i i
kind of um i i hand waved a bit
this statement that we can think of the
causal network as being like a
skeletonized lorenzian manifold
and and therefore you can think of the
you know the hypergraph as limiting to
something like a romanian manifold
um but that i didn't particularly
justify i just kind of showed you some
pictures that were a little bit you know
that they kind of suggested it might be
true
um so the first question i want to
address today is under what conditions
do you actually get
a manifold-like structure appearing in
the hypograph and in the causal network
and as it turns out
rather excitingly and a slight spoiler
alert the sort of the minimal set of
conditions that you need
to guarantee that the resultant
hypergraph and the resultant causal
network in the limiting cases
are manifold-like and they they limit to
sort of finite-dimensional manifold-like
structures
the the minimal sets of constraints that
force that to happen are exactly the
einstein field equations
so you know as long as you as long as
your hypergraph limits to something like
a romanian manifold
it's guaranteed to be compatible with
general relativity and to exhibit
effects of gravitation
and that's you know that's kind of
that's that's the grand prize that we're
going to try to work through
or work towards in this lecture uh we
may not get all the way but fortunately
the next lecture slot has been
intentionally
enlarged in case we we need to um fill
it with some things we didn't get to
today or sorry or this morning sorry
because i think that the
next slot is in the afternoon so anyway
like i said the
first question we want to address is
under what situations if we're given a
warfare model system
how can we determine if the hypergraph
that we get out when it when we take a
continuum limit as the hypergraph gets
arbitrarily large
you know how do we guarantee that the
that that hypograph is indeed a romanian
manifold
and uh so you know here's an example of
a hypergraph of a set substitution
system
uh represented in terms of hypergraph
transformations if we run it for 10
evolution steps it does some slightly
odd things it's not immediately clear
what's going on
but if we run it for another 10
evolution steps we start to see this
kind of
uh this something looks like a grid-like
structure start to appear
and in fact if we run it for a thousand
evolution steps we see a very very clear
grid-like structure
that looks very much like kind of
asymptotically flat manifold with i mean
there's a bit of curvature towards the
boundaries
but uh sort of in the center you can
think of this as being asymptotically
flat
so you know just by kind of eyeballing
it we can see this is something that's
kind of
that's manifold-like but how can we make
that idea a little bit more precise
and how can we determine given a rule
how do we determine whether it's going
to produce a hypergraph that's like a
manifold or a hypergraph that's
something a bit more crazy so to do that
or before i can really address that
question um what i would
i'm gonna have to sort of introduce a
few pieces of technical machinery
so um the the first thing is to notice
that because these hypergraphs are not
manifolds
uh ordinary concepts from differential
geometry like uh richie curvature
riemann curvature
gauss curvature all of these kinds of
things that you know that there isn't
really a notion of that that's that's
defined a priori on a hypergraph we have
to sort of we have to figure out
uh sort of quantities that are analogous
to these ones that will limit to them
as you know if we take an appropriately
large uh
large system so um the first question i
kind of want to pose is can we
can we define a quantity on the
hypographs that preserves the standard
geometrical intuition for the ricci
scalar curvature
uh for for you know for a discrete space
so just to remind you
you know the standard geometrical
intuition is you if you're
if you're defining the richie scalar
curvature at a point in some some
manifold a point in some space
what you're really asking is if we take
a a ball of radius epsilon
uh you know in that manifold we take its
volume and we compare its volume to a
ball of radius epsilon in flat euclidean
space
what is the discrepancy between those
two volumes what is what is effectively
the correction factor that appears
and the second order correction term uh
in you know in powers of epsilon
is related to this quantity r which is
the richie scalar curvature so it's 3g
scalar that gives you the discrepancy
between the volumes of a ball and
manifold
and a ball in correspondingly flat space
um
in and that is in the limit as epsilon
goes to zero um so
so i'm going to use the notation b
epsilon p to denote a ball a finite ball
of radius epsilon
centered at point p in the manifold so
the question is can we define a notion
of can we define a quantity that has
basically the same geometrical intuition
for a hypergraph well actually you know
that's not too difficult right you
we have a notion we can we can define a
notion of a flat hypograph
we can define a notion of a curve
typograph and then you know effectively
what you're really asking is if we if we
look at the volume of a ball
in other words we pick a point and we
look at all the points that are adjacent
to that point and all the points that
are adjacent to those points and we grow
out
we grow out a ball of graph distance
epsilon uh and we look we just count the
number of nodes inside that
inside that finite ball uh that's that's
like a notion of volume
and we can just compare that to the
volume we would get in for the case of a
flat hypograph
and define again the an analog of the
richie scalar that is the second order
correction
so that's that's actually what we're
going to do uh that's kind of that's the
big picture idea but i'd like to you
know in the interest of being
reasonably complete i'd like to make
that a bit more mathematically uh
precise
so we're going to use an equivalent
definition of the richie scalar that
turns out to generalize a bit more
nicely to the
concept of a hypergraph because it
doesn't require us to define
you know off the bat what a flat
hypograph is versus a curved type of
graph
so the equivalent definition i'm going
to use is we say
uh you you pick a point p and you pick a
nearby point q
that's a distance delta away from p and
then what you do is you you grow out a
ball of radius epsilon around
p and then you map all the points on b
epsilon p
but by parallel transports to points on
b epsilon q
and then what you're asking is what is
the average distance between a point on
b epsilon p
and its corresponding point after
parallel transport on b epsilon q
and then uh the ratio of that average
distance to the actual distance delta
between the centers of the two balls
gives you the in the limit as epsilon
and delta goes to zero
gives you again up to second order uh
the the richie scalar and again that's a
quantity that we can immediately define
for the case of a hypergraph so to kind
of walk you through in
in complete i mean as long as you really
understand the geometrical intuition
that's kind of all that matters for the
rest of this proof but
in in the interests of preserving
mathematical rigor i'd like to sort of
walk you through exactly how we can do
that uh
formally so what we can do is we can
generalize the richie scalar to an
arbitrary metric space
so if we have a metric space x equipped
with a metric d
um then this concept of a volume measure
as
as defined in terms of a finite ball we
can generalize to a probability measure
defined on that metric space
and then the average distance between uh
this notion of the average distance
between points after parallel transport
on the two balls
will generalize to the notion of the
vacherstein distance the transportation
distance
between those probability measures so to
to sort of clarify exactly what that
means if we're given a polish space x
with a metric d
and it's equipped with a borel sigma
algebra then we can define a random walk
which is just a family of probability
measures
each of the form mx such that each
measure mx has a finite first moment
and the map from the from the point x
onto the measure mx is itself a
measurable map
and then we can define a set pi which is
the set
for for a given x and y which is the set
of all transportations of the measure mx
to the measure m y
and then the vacherstein distance the
transportation distance is just the
minimal cost of that procedure so
the you know the the standard intuition
is it's like you know you consider each
measure to be
to be like a pile of earth or something
and then you're
you're basically asking what is that
what is the minimum amount of work that
i need to do in order to disassemble the
measure at position x
transport it over to position y and
reassemble it at position y
so it's an optimal transportation
distance defined as an emphemum
over this set of measures pi uh where
you know where one measure
projects onto mx and the other measure
projects onto my so you can think of it
as being the couplings between all
random walks
projecting onto mx and those random
walks that project onto my
um so then what given this notion of
average distance
in in terms of the matches line distance
we can just immediately port over
you know the standard definition of the
ricci scalar to to use the vacherstein
distance instead so we can again define
it as being the discrepancy
between the metric distance between
points p and q and the vacherstein
distance between points p and q
up to second order so that gives us this
notion of what's called the olivier
richie
scalar curvature uh in in the direction
p q for points p and q in the metric
space
it's called the olivier ricci scale of
curvature because it was developed by
uh uh by john olivier building on work
by people like robin form and
jurgen yost and others there's there's a
kind of there's a big tradition in
measure theory
of people trying to define notions of
curvature that apply to arbitrary metric
spaces
so uh this is really nice the the
olivier richie scala curvature is a
really nice definition
one of the reasons for which is that we
we can guarantee it preserves the
natural
geometrical intuition because in the
special case where
x is a is a romanian manifold and d is a
romanian metric
and and so so the the the volume measure
although
the probability measure on the on the
metric space becomes the romanian volume
measure
then kappa the olivier richie scalar
curvature becomes exactly
the the romanian richie scala curvature
up to some multiplicative constant i
think
um and so that gives us a kind of formal
justification for this
you know hand idea that i mentioned that
you can think of the measures mp and mq
as being the volumes of generalized
balls centered at points p and q
so that's that's a very general abstract
definition but we're not interested so
much in the general abstract definition
we only care about the
the the special case where uh you know
our metric space is a hypograph
um i should mention also by the way that
if you if you're interested in the kind
of measure theoretic foundations of this
that we're only using the kind of boring
basher stein distance the first order of
asherstein distance
um there are many many higher order
generalizations that involve you know
high you know effectively higher order
integrals uh
over over epsilon um but we're you know
because we're interested in
transportation distances we only care
about the one rasherstein distance
so in the special case where we have a
discrete metric space this becomes the
discrete optimal transportation distance
otherwise known as the the
multi-marginal transportation distance
which is effectively identical except
the integral reduces down to a sum
and now that this notion that we're that
we're minimizing over
those you know those measures that
project onto mx producted with the
measures that project onto my
that becomes very precisely a statement
that that these two sums are satisfied
um so then if we have uh once we have a
notion of
of you know vaccinating distance for
discrete probability measures
and therefore a notion of curvature for
discrete probability measures we can
specialize even further to the case of a
directed hypergraph which of course is
the case that we're we're actually
interested in
so if we consider a directed hypergraph
uh then
now the vaccine we can write the vaccine
distance in a very explicit way
um where so uh when obviously the the
metric distance d
between points you and between vertices
u and v is the standard metric distance
that you'd expect on a hypergraph it's
the number of directed hyperedges that
you traverse
when moving from vertex v sorry from
vertex u uh to vertex v
and then the and then the probability
measures are essentially the you know
the the the finite gd6 balls
uh that we grow out in the hypergraph by
considering kind of adjacency structure
that i defined before and so you're
effectively minimizing
over uh all of the hyperedges that you
have to traverse from you
up to the the the headset of a given
hyperedge and then
and then all the vertices you have to
traverse from the tail set b
uh up up to vertex v which is the you
know the one that you're
uh which is sort of the the destination
point the end point and epsilon is the
coupling
which actually for our case we can just
assume is one because
we're only interested really in in the
case of torsion-free metrics
where you know essentially the distance
from u to v is always the same as the
distance from v to u
if we relax that condition and so we
allowed values of epsilon that were that
were sort of
you know what that had values of one in
one direction and two in the other
direction for instance
then obviously we'd get a torsion metric
uh which would we should have various
implications for
for the structure of the geometry of the
space but because we're interested in
general relativity
and because you know general relativity
in the einsteinian formulation is a
torsion-free theory
we're going to assume that epsilon is
one for all hyperedges so as i say we're
effectively minimizing
over sort of over the uh incoming
vertices to a tails
to the tail set a and the outcoming
versus
outgoing uh hyperedges from the from the
headset b
of each individual hyperedge
okay so then once we have a notion of
the vacherstein distance between
uh between probability measures in in
the directed hypergraph case that
immediately gives us a way of defining
the olivier richie curvature
for a given directed hyperedge uh that
as i say you know
now now preserves the geometrical
intuition that it's you know it's the
second order correction term that
appears when we consider the you know
the discrepancy between the volume of a
ball
of radius epsilon and the hypograph uh
that
that has some curvature and the volume
of a ball of radius epsilon in a kind of
flat grid-like hypergraph
um if we wanted to we can these measures
uh mu mu a and mu b out we can write
sort of completely explicitly in terms
of these minimization procedures but
that's uh
that's that's a detail that again those
of you who are interested in the measure
theory of it i'm happy to discuss this
uh with you afterwards but this is not
not completely important for the large
scale picture of the derivation
so here's you know here's the
geometrical picture for what's actually
going on
so if you take uh you know if we can say
we take a point in the hypograph we look
at the points that are adjacent to it we
look at the points that are adjacent to
those points we grow out some finite
geodesic ball
then uh you know if we have if we have a
flat grid-like hypergraph like this
then the volume of that ball is going to
is going to grow like ah
sorry it's going to grow like epsilon
like like the volume of the ball or like
the like the radius of the ball
if for a flat for a flat grid-like space
that's two-dimensional
it's going to grow like well roughly
roughly like pi r squared pi epsilon
squared
and for a flat three dimensional space
is going to grow roughly like the volume
of a sphere four thirds
of pi epsilon cubed and so on
and so so this gives us a way of
determining the the effective
dimensionality of a hypergraph by just
looking at how that you know
how this growth rate uh uh sort of how
well how this quantity n that is the the
number of hyper edges we can reach by
kind of
by traversing a metric distance of
epsilon or r
um how that scales with the value of r
so
so in in the case of a of a perfectly
flat spatial hypergraph it's going to
scale exactly like r to the n
where n is the dimensionality of the
space and we can see that here so for
the one two and three dimensional
spatial hypergraphs i showed here these
are the resulting growth rates that you
see
now uh there's obviously there's a
slight tail off that you see here for
the case of a finite grid
that's simply there because of boundary
effects uh and
for for small hypergraphs boundary
effects do become quite significant and
we're going to try to ignore them
wherever we can but
just just be aware that you may see kind
of drop-offs appearing
and and that's that's essentially why
okay
so so now thanks to this kind of measure
theoretic foundation in terms of in
terms of asher stein distances and
transportation metrics
uh we now have a formal justification
for saying that the
the second order correction for the case
of a curved spatial hypograph
the second order correction term to the
uh to this quantity n of r
is going to be proportional to the
richie scalar curvature of that
hypergraph as considered as a discrete
metric space
so then what we can do is we can just
take any arbitrary hypergraph
and by using this logarithmic distance
this logarithmic logarithmic difference
formula
we can construct an estimate for its
dimension we can construct an estimate
for the for the first order exponent
which is which is going to be n
so for instance giving this the the the
sort of flat grid-like hypergraph that i
grew right at the beginning
we can see that that you know neglecting
boundary effects it limits to something
that's roughly two-dimensional which is
exactly what we
what we see if we take something that's
a bit more complicated like this
you can see that you know this structure
also limits to something two-dimensional
but that's a little bit less easy to see
by eye but it is nevertheless something
we can see just by explicitly doing the
computation
um and the the nice thing about this is
that even you know these two
you can see a kind of they're nice
manifold-like structures they they have
kind of obvious smoothness properties
but even hypergraphs that don't have
obvious smoothness properties where
there's no
obvious induced geometry in the limit
like here you know i defy anyone here to
to
sort of uh to to designate a nice sort
of geometrical description of what this
hypergraph actually is
but nevertheless that doesn't stop us
from defining its dimension and
therefore by extension
from defining its curvature so in this
particular case this is a
you can see by just sort of by examining
the the the lines
by examining the growth rates and again
attempting to to neglect the the effects
of the
of the presence of a boundary uh you can
see it limits to something that's
roughly 2.7 dimensional
so uh that and that's obviously
indicating to us that because we're
considering
defining dimension not in terms of like
basis vectors but defining it in terms
of volumes
we're really constructing a course
discrete approximation to the hausdorff
dimension as opposed to the topological
dimension
and so because we can have effectively
fractal structures there's nothing to
prevent the
the the the the the our approximation to
the household dimension there's nothing
to prevent that
from being uh sort of a non-integer
quantity which is exactly what we see
here so
actually you know generically these
hypergraphs will limit to something that
doesn't exist in a kind of nice integer
dimensional space but that's okay you
know our techniques are sufficiently
general that we can
we can deal with that um
okay so that gives us a way of defining
the the ricci scalar
um but and that's already kind of
interesting because of course the rigi
scalar is a term that appears in the
einstein field equations
um but to do you know the the full
einstein field equations are
defined not purely in terms of the
richie scalar but actually in terms of
this directional quantity which is the
richie curvature tensor
um and of course the you know the the we
can think of the richie scalar as being
the the trace of the rishi coverage
attention or the average of the reaching
curvature tensor you know averaged out
over over
multiple time-like projections that's a
concept that we'll come to later on
because it's kind of important
um and so again we can ask can we define
a quantity on the
uh you know on a spatial hypergraph or
on a causal network that preserves the
the geometrical intuition that we have
for what the regis
what the reaching curvature tensor
actually is now this becomes really
important
for the case of of a causal network
because of course unlike
a hypergraph which which you know in
which everything is kind of just
spatially separated
in a causal network uh all of our edges
have directionality because the because
the you know
the edges themselves denote time-like
separations so there isn't
a neat way given a causal network there
isn't a neat way of growing out a
symmetrical ball
in the same way as you can in the
hypograph the main reason being because
the hypograph is like a romanian
manifold
uh so so you know all the eigenvalues of
your metric
have the same sign but the causal
network is like a lorenzian manifold
in which you know you have one
eigenvalue that has an opposite sign
because
because of the time like separation so
because of that
you can't just grow out a finite
geodesic ball you have to effectively
grow out a geodesic cone
and to do that requires defining a
projection direction and to do that
you have to define a curvature tensor so
uh so you know
the standard geometrical intuition for
the for what the reaching curvature
tensor is
is your especially if you specify a
time-like projection direction it's
telling you the ratio of the volume of a
conical region oriented in that
projection direction that consists of
you know geodesic segments
of some of some infinitesimal length
epsilon that goes to zero
uh to the volume of the of a conical
region in flat euclidean space so it's
in exactly the same way as the ricci
scalar was telling us that the
discrepancy between the volume of a ball
in the manifold and the volume of a ball
in flat space the the ricci scale the
reachy curvature tensor is telling us
the discrepancy between the volume of a
cone oriented in a particular direction
and the volume of a cone of cone of
corresponding length
in in flat euclidean space um
and so so how can we go about defining
something like that
um well i i don't really know the
optimal way of doing it i just kind of i
found a way of doing it
uh which which considers uh an even more
general quantity which is obviously the
riemann curvature tensor which uh
you know is is a measure of the degree
to which uh sort of geometrical
information fails to be preserved under
under parallel transport so if you take
a vector and you parallel transport it
around some closed curve
the the riemann curvature is the thing
that tells you uh you know
effectively the the the deviation in the
initial angle of that vector and the
final angle of that vector
after parallel transport um and so then
if you
if we have if we can define a notion of
riemann curvature that works on
the works on hypergraphs and on causal
networks then we're then we're up and
running
them then it's all plain sailing because
then we know that the riemann curvature
tensor
although the rigid curvature tensor can
then be derived by just taking the
uh the the tensor contraction of the
riemann curvature between the first and
third indices and it's
uh you know obviously well we could take
it between any pair of indices we we
either get zero
or we get plus or minus three curvature
so uh but
you know to do that we need to have some
notion of parallel transport and we need
to have some notion of hellonomy so we
need to have
some notion of of you know how much how
much does geometrical information fail
to get preserved when it's parallel
transported
but you'll remember that we already kind
of introduced a notion of parallel
transport before
when we considered the vacherstein
distance because we because we kind of
we we now have this
we have we have this formal
correspondence that allows us to to say
that the
the vaccine distance between probability
measures is is directly analogous
to the average distance between points
on two g finite geodesic balls
mapped under parallel transport so can
we make that
correspondence a bit more precise so uh
let's let's actually do that but uh
obviously before i get to that let me
just quickly recap some some things
about romanian geometry that we're going
to
make use of so uh before we can define
those notions we have to define a
connection
now we actually already implicitly
defined a connection before when i said
before
that uh in the definition of the ricci
scalar we were going to assume that
these
that these uh variables epsilon were
going to be one and i said we were going
to do that in order to ensure that we
ended up with the torsion-free metric so
that distances from u to v would always
be the same as the distances from v to u
implicitly that choice of values of
epsilon was uh
the choice of a connection and it was in
particular the choice of the metric
connection the torsion free connection
which uh some of you will know in in
standard romanian geometry
is given in terms of the christopher
symbols um so so
as long as we if we stick with that
decision to set uh epsilon to be kind of
to have a value of unity everywhere
then then we can proceed by just
assuming that our metric connection
is given by by christopher symbols which
are which are themselves the first order
derivatives
of the metric tensor and the you know
the the standard the geometrical
intuition for what those christopher
symbols are telling you
is if if we take if we consider the set
of basis vectors for the manifold
locally
at each point you could ask how if i
move from from one point to a
neighboring point how does that set of
basis vectors change how do their angles
get distorted
and that's effectively what the
christopher symbols are telling you
so then uh it once we have if we make it
if we've made the choice of the
levisovita connection we can then write
the riemann curvature tensor explicitly
in terms of them
so in other words we're writing them in
terms as a linear combination of second
derivatives of the metric
um and then uh this comes on i guess to
some things i touched on yesterday about
you know what exactly is the difference
between an inertial frame and a
non-inertial frame
well in a locally flat frame an inertial
frame then we know that all of them the
christopher symbols vanish but their
first derivatives don't and so there's a
nice kind of very neat
uh representation of the riemann
curvature that we can write in terms of
in terms of
sort of second-order derivatives of the
metric uh but for for arbitrary
reference frames that you might consider
in general relativity then the
christopher symbols are
globally non-vanishing but but they
always vanish locally because
you can always approximate you know this
this notion of local level symmetry
tells you that even
in general relativity if you look kind
of locally at the manifold it's
everything kind of behaves like special
relativity everything behaves as though
it's purely inertial
okay so um so now let's let's discuss in
a bit more detail about
uh how we how we think about this this
intuition of growing a you know a finite
cone in one of these manifolds
so if we pick a coordinate system so if
we've got a point in the manifold we can
pick a coordinate system where all of
the gd6 becomes
effectively straight lines through the
origin that's the coordinate system as
seen by
by a normal observer by an observer
moving normal to a space like
hypersurface
and so we call those geodesic normal
coordinates and so those are the
that's the coordinate system that we're
going to assume locally when we're
growing out these these space-time cones
so then locally the metric is roughly
euclidean just like it is in you know
if you if you consider if you consider
you know going back to the to the pure
sort of romanian hypograph case
where basically locally everything
behaves like it's kind of a flat space
and it's only when you go out to certain
finite distance
that you start to see the effects of
curvature so the metric tensor therefore
we can write in in terms of the
euclidean metric which is just the
kronecker delta function
and then we can do it we can do a a
power series expansion we can we can do
a taylor expansion
along a radial jd stick so along a gdc
oriented in a particular radial
direction
uh and with respect to the geodesic
normal coordinates that then gives us
the second order correction term
and it's one third of the of the riemann
curvature tensor projected in the
direction x k xl
so that and so then uh so the the the
this taylor series
the taylor expansion is being given in
terms of these things called jacobi
fields
which are uh which are sort of tangent
space you know
given a particular geodesic you can ask
what's the tangent space what's the
you know what what's the space that's
made up of of gd6 oriented in the
tangent plane
uh for that for that particular geodesic
um and then that gives us a notion of a
jacobi field and those are the things
with respect to which
we're doing the taylor expansion um all
of which is just there to formally
justify this statement
that if you consider the the the growth
rate d mu g
of of you know of a cone of length
uh a cone projected in direction x uh
with respect to some lorentzian manifold
it's equal to d mu d mu euclidean which
is the associated volume of
a cone in flat euclidean space with the
second order correction term given by
the projection of the reachy curvature
tensor in the timeline direction
uh in you know in the direction of which
you're orienting the code
okay now that's the that's all the sort
of
that's the standards you know romanian
geometry technology but how do we port
that over
to the case of of discrete structures
like hypergraphs and causal networks
well as i say i'm not yet convinced that
the derivation i came up with is optimal
it's just one that i found that
that works um so what the the the thing
i
decided to do was was to consider uh
instead of the romanian curvature to
consider what's called the sectional
curvature because that
you know defining things in terms of
holonomy is a little bit complicated
uh and at least for me it's it's kind of
hard for me to get my head around
whereas sectional curvature has a much
clearer intuition behind it the you know
the sectional curvature is saying uh you
know if we if we take a point p
and we look at two uh linearly
independent tangent vectors or
actually in the uh in the more in the
sort of more mathematically
straightforward case we if we let them
be orthonormal vectors
and we look at all of the gd6 that
emanate from that point p
we look at the gd6 that are oriented in
direction u and orange in the direction
v
where u and v are those orthonormal
vectors then that gives us a tangent
plane that gives us a sigma p
and then we can just ask what is the
what is the gaussian curvature
of that of that resultant surface so you
know but by considering all gd6 oriented
in direction u
or gd6 oriented in direction v you know
obtaining some curves tangent plane
uh then you know effectively what is the
gauss curvature of that surface
that gives us a notion of sectional
curvature and if we can define a notion
of sectional curvature then we're kind
of okay
because the sectional curvature once you
know u and v the sectional curvature is
kind of trivial to rewrite
in terms of the ribbond curvature so you
know once you have one you effectively
have the other
so how do we do that well again this is
this is a quantity that we can
immediately define
just sort of uh immediately translates
to the case of an arbitrary metric space
so uh if you look at basically what
you're asking is
if we if we project a geodesic in one
direction uh you know
in direction u and we project a g d
second direction v and we look at the
endpoints of those gd6 and then we look
at a nearby point
which also projects gd6 in directions u
and v
then effectively what we're asking is
what is the average distance between the
endpoints of the gd6 or you know uh
emanating from one
from one point and the gd600 anything
from the other point what is that
what is that average distance as a ratio
of the actual metric distance between
those two points
and so so if we denote that metric
distance as usual by by this
by delta and if we denote the the
geodesic
length as being epsilon then and we
denote the endpoints as being
x because they are effectively the
exponential map in in
the they're given in romanian in the
romanian case by an exponential map
then uh effectively what we're asking is
what you know what is the difference
between the
the the average distance between those
two endpoints uh d x
x d x y and and delta and so
uh again uh what we've discovered is
that up to the second order in epsilon
it's going to be given by the sectional
curvature oriented in directions u and v
which
confusingly i've denoted v and w here
but that's uh
ignore that it's the same idea these are
just kind of two effectively orthonormal
uh orthonormal directions in this
arbitrary metric space
um and so this is something that we can
we can compute um
and and excitingly we know that if we
define the quantity in this way
then it's actually provably compatible
with the derivation we did before of the
ricci scalar because if we take the
uh we know that that taking that taking
a trace of the curvature tensor should
yield
the richie scalar and taking a trace is
effectively the same as averaging out
over all vectors w of you know the
sectional curvature for
uh orthonormal directions v and w so uh
if we do that
what we're basically doing you know
because what we're asking you know you
you have this
you have this pair of gd6 at this point
you have this other pair of gd6 at that
point we're asking the average distance
between those two points if we take an
average out over all possible pairs of
gd6
uh or at least all possible uh pairs
where where one geodesic is kind of
being swept out in all possible
directions
what you're growing is a finite gd6 ball
of radius epsilon
and so what you're essentially asking is
what is the average distance between a
point on that finite geodesic ball and a
point on
a nearby finite geodesic ball mapped out
to parallel transport
but that's exactly the olivier vg scalar
that we defined before
so so this again allows us to to
introduce the notion of taking a a
tensor contraction
um or a trace over over the um
over the sexual curvature and confirming
that just like it would in romanian
geometry
you know we recover the reached scalar
curvature
okay so that's that's kind of again
that's that's the technical machinery
that we need in order to be able to
formally justify what we're about to do
but what we're about to do is actually
really simple we're just gonna we're
gonna take a point in the causal network
we're gonna grow out a space-time cone
of length t
that starts at some starts at that given
vertex it's oriented in a particular
time-like direction so in other words
it's oriented
in the direction of a particular time
like geodesic through the causal network
and we're going to ask if we count the
number just like we did for the the
hypograph when we counted
n of r for for varying r and we looked
at how it's scaled
we're going to ask how does the growth
rate of a of a space-time cone
uh sort of change as we as we modify its
length
so again for for a causal network that
corresponds to flat and dimensional
space
we expect it to grow like t to the n uh
where uh where t is where t is the
length of the cone where t is
effectively the number of of space like
hypersurfaces that's being intersected
by the cone if you like
but now we we have formal justification
for saying that if we have a if we have
a causal network that corresponds to
curved and dimensional space
then there will be a correction factor
up to second order and that correction
factor will be proportional to the
time-like projection of the
olivier-richie curvature tensor
in the direction of which we're growing
the cone so let's let's actually see
that so if we take a really simple case
where we have a just a space-time cone
and a causal network
that in this case it's a it's a grit
it's a perfect kind of grid-like causal
network
that we can think of as corresponding to
sort of flat one plus one-dimensional
minkowski space
and we can compute dimension estimates
so again
you you can see that that uh you know
neglecting boundary effects
and and ignoring the sort of the the the
perturbations that are effectively grid
artifacts
you can see that there's limits to
something that's two-dimensional which
matches kind of what we what we were
able to eyeball just by
by looking at the calls by looking at
say an embedding of the causal network
and uh the the the precise sense that i
in which i'm using this this phrase the
time-like projection is exactly the same
as the sense that we introduced
yesterday
so uh when when we were talking about
how we were constructing these
foliations of the causal network
and i said that essentially locally you
have to make some gauge choice
uh where you're saying um you you're
defining some
some lapse function alpha some shift
vector beta the lapse function tells you
the time like distance between the point
on on a hypersurface and the
corresponding point on the next
hypersurface the shift vector beta tells
you the spatial distance between the
places where those updating events got
applied
uh there should be a plus sign here
sorry about that i'll modify that and
re-upload the slides in a minute but so
so then uh once you have a value of
alpha and beta you can define a normal
direction to that space like
hypersurface
and then the time vector is basically
just that normal direction it's it's
it's the normal it's the direction as
followed by by an observer
in the gd6 normal coordinate frame and
so so the the time vector is affected
you know
is the thing that's normal to to that
particular space like hypersurface and
that's the direction
that we're we're growing the space-time
code in so effectively when when we
define
when we define this face-time cone and
we define it its initial direction
we are locally defining a foliation of
the causal network
um so as i say this is a fairly
straightforward case here's a more
natural case
this is an actual hypergraph produced by
an actual set substitution rule
uh you can see it limits to the
hypergraph itself limits to something
that's roughly kind of manifold like
and so does its causal network and just
as we can construct dimension estimates
in terms of finite geodesic falls on the
hypograph
we can construct domestic dimension
estimates for space-time in terms of
finite gdc cones in the causal network
and that's kind of that that's that's
what we're trying to do uh here here's
another example
so this particular one uh you know
happens to be sort of an asymptotically
flat manifold
just like this one is so that's not
super interesting you can see that
if we do the dimension estimate for the
causal network you see you can see the
asymptotic flatness here
you know the dimension is roughly
constant and neglecting boundary effects
but if we consider something that limits
to like a hyperbolic space so here's a
hypergraph transformation rule that
produces a hypergraph that has a sort of
the signature of a hyperbolic space so
does its causal network you know
the the sort of the structure of the
spacetime uh roughly reflects the
structure of the space like
hypersurfaces
and so if we do the dimension estimates
here you can see that although they do
limit to something that's that's of
finite dimension
that there are as in addition to the
boundary effects there are also
curvature effects there are there are
second order correction
uh correction effects that in the
hypergraph case we can attribute to the
ricci scalar
and in the in the space-time causal
network case we can attribute to the
richie curvature tensor
okay so that gives us a a way of of
using some
notions and ideas that that are borrowed
from re-money and geometry and applying
them in a sensible way
to to our hypographs and our causal
networks but you know what does any of
this have to do with general relativity
i promised you at the beginning
that we were going to derive general
relativity we were going to derive the
einstein field equations
how are we actually going to do that
well um it's worth noting if you kind of
explore these systems for long enough
you begin to find that there are
instances of these hypograph
transformation rules and these causal
networks
that have a property that's extremely
undesirable namely
that when we try to take a limit they
don't seem to limit to something that's
finite dimensional so
an obvious case where that could happen
is in a causal network like this so if
we have a
really simple hypograph transformation
rule that takes kind of two nodes
two self loops x x and replaces them
with three self loops x
x x then the causal network is going to
grow exponentially that you know the
number of events they're not and
therefore the number of possible causal
relations grows exponentially with each
successive
with each excessive step in time with
each successive uh space like
hypersurface
and so because we we have an
exponentially growing causal network it
means that if we try to grow a finite
geodesic
cone if we try to grow a space-time cone
to estimate the dimensionality of the
space
that the estimate of the dimensionality
of the space is going to keep increasing
as the length of the code increases in
other words if we try to take an
appropriate continuum limit
it isn't going to work the the the
dimension and curvature estimates don't
work
because effectively this causal network
limits to an infinite dimensional space
because you know the big because the the
volume of a cone
grows exponentially as you know as the
uh
as the value of this quantity c sub t
grows exponentially as the value of t
goes to infinity um so we can't we want
to avoid this case right this is this is
a bad case this is a case where we get
an unphysical hypograph
and an unphysical causal network without
a nice finite dimensional
manifold structure so how can we avoid
that happening well we have because we
have a way of estimating
uh what the dimension is we can actually
formulate this essentially as a calculus
of variations problems
as an externalization problem so what we
want to do is we want to say let's
let's find the minimal set of
constraints that need to be that need to
be satisfied
in order to guarantee that we end up
with a with a manifold that's sort of
finite dimensional in the limit
so what we can do is we have a way of
computing
what is the deviation from a from an
ordinary flat and dimensional space
right
it's just it's it we know that that
deviation is given up to second order by
the projection of the riemann curvature
tense
of the olivier rigid curvature tensor um
so
essentially what we want to do is we
want to find appropriate constraints on
the curvature
to ensure that in the infinite limit uh
you know we don't end up with something
infinite dimensional because
if effectively if the curvature is
allowed to grow without bound
then in the infinite limit what we're
really discovering when we consider
these these exponentially growing causal
networks
is that in the appropriate infinite
limit it becomes impossible to
distinguish
between a kind of monotonically
increasing curvature and
an actual global increase in the
effective dimension so in other words
what
if we consider this to be to be the
dimension correction factor or what
we'll call the dimension anomaly
what we're saying by saying that we want
the causal network to limit to something
that's finite dimensional
is that in the infinite limit we want
this we want the global average
of that dimension anomaly to limit to
zero or the sorry or more precisely we
want the rate of change of the dimension
anomaly
to limit to zero um because if it limits
to something non-zero
what that's saying is the dimension
anomaly is growing with each you know
with each step t
and so so in other words the the causal
cone is getting larger and larger with
each step t
uh and therefore you know we we can
deduce that we have a situation that's
something like this
where effectively the number of the
number of events that exist on the next
space like hypersurface
is is is exponentially related to the
number of events that existed on the
previous hypersurface
so if you have a monotonically
increasing value of this global
dimension anomaly that's an indication
that in the infinite limit you're not
going to get something finite
dimensional
so how do we compute this global
dimension normally well we just take
the we take the the the volume average
over the causal network
of this uh second order correction term
so uh to do that what we're doing is we
so we're averaging out over every point
in space time over every event
in the causal network and we're also
averaging out over all possible uh
space-time cones so effectively all
possible time-like
directions all possible gd6 and if we
take the olivier ricci curvature tensor
and we average out of all possible
time-like projections
that's equivalent to taking a trace of
of the of the tensor and so that will
give us the space
the four dimensional in the in this in
the physical case it will give us the
four dimensional space time
olivier ricci scalar uh averaged out as
a volume average over the whole causal
network so we're averaging out over this
this
this elementary volume element dmu g
that i defined a little while ago i
think
uh over wherever it was over here so
you know this is this is the elementary
volume element in the causal network
we're averaging out over that
multiplied by this by by the trace of
the olivier ricci curvature tensor which
is going to give us the olivier richie
uh
curvature scalar which is r so that's
that that's the global dimension anomaly
summed over the whole causal network
and what we're saying is we want that
quantity to limit to zero
as the causal network becomes you know
becomes infinitely large
so in other words we want uh delta s
over delta g
to converge to zero okay so what does
that tell us well
now what we're going to do is we're
going to make a an assumption that we do
not yet know how to justify
mathematically although we're hoping
that uh that we might um
actually i think as a consequence of
jin's project we might be able to
to actually have a proof of this next
step uh within within the sum school
which would be really cool
but what we're going to do is we're
going to assume that the the underlying
causal network
dynamics are ergodic are weakly ergodic
so in other words um you know we're
assuming that the the actual hypograph
replacement dynamics are sufficiently
complex and sufficiently ergotic
that they can be treated as effectively
random
why well because the a weak ergodicity
assumption allows us
analytically to justify the statement
that in in the continuum limit as the
limit as the causal network becomes
infinite
we can replace this sum with an integral
if we don't have an ergodicity
assumption
then there's no guarantee that we can do
that but assuming that there is uh
there is weak ergodicity in these causal
networks then we can replace the sum
with an integral
and so we get the integral with respect
to the elementary volume element d4x
of multiplied by square root minus g
which is the you know which is the
the the the eigenvalue of the the eigen
which gives you
the eigenvalues of the metric tensor uh
multiplied by the trace of the olivier
richie curvature tensor which is the
earlier varices scalar
and so we get this integral but of
course that's not just any integral
that is exactly the einstein-hilbert
action
in in sort of classical general
relativity with the ordinary standard uh
general relativistic lagrangian density
square root minus gr and so the
statement that the causal network limits
to something that's finite dimensional
and therefore the global dimension
anomaly the rate of change of the global
dimension anomaly converges to zero
in the continuum limit with weaker
gadicity becomes exactly the statement
that the vacuum einstein hilbert action
is extremized and so we
so once once we have that we can just do
it we can just do the standard
derivation
we take a functional derivative of the
of the of of this
einstein hibernate action with respect
to the inverse metric tensor we assume
zero surface terms
and we conclude that this quantity delta
s by delta g converges to zero
exactly in the case where r a b minus
one half r g a b
uh converges to zero and so we can
conclude that
if the if the causal network is ergodic
and it limits to a finite dimensional
manifold
then uh we can prove in the continuum
limit that the vacuum einstein field
equations have to be satisfied
which is pretty exciting so that means
that from almost nothing you can
immediately build up kind of a a really
quite foundational feature of our
universe which is general relativity
um uh one one thing you may have noticed
is that
uh we actually implicitly used causal
invariants i mean
you might be wondering what you know
what does causal invariance have to do
with any of this why did i bother going
through in so much detail what causal
and variance is and
how it relates to things yesterday well
causal invariance is exactly the thing
that
that allows you to take these time-like
projections when we construct these
space-time cones because
when we averaged out it here um when we
averaged out over all possible time-like
projections
we have we were assuming that
independent of the local choice of
coordinate frame independent of which
time-like geodesic you projected the
cone in
that the combinatorial structure of the
causal network would always be the same
but of course that's that that's only
true if the combinatorial structure of
the causal network is invariant under
the choice of updating order is
invariant under the choice
of foliation into space like
hypersurfaces so it's really
so actually in addition to the the
assumption that the causal network
limits to something finite dimensional
and the assumption that it's weakly
ergodic we're also assuming that it's
that it satisfies causal invariance
because that's the thing that allows us
to take the average over all possible
time like projection directions without
the
without the microscopic structure of the
causal network actually changing
that's uh so that's an important thing
to to kind of note so
but as long as we have those three
properties we can prove any such causal
network that satisfies those properties
necessarily satisfies general relativity
or at least the vacuum case of the
einstein field equations
okay that's that's kind of cool and of
course it immediately gives us things
that we can test you know
we know that in ordinary space time if
it you know if we have a space time
that's satisfied that has an einstein
metric and it satisfies the
the vacuum machine field equations it
will it will satisfy the the g basic
equation you can prove that just by
taking
basically just by using the principle of
least action by considering if you have
a time like
if you have a time like gd sick you can
think of a time-like path
uh and we can denote its action as just
an integral over over the space-time
volume element or sorry this is the
spacetime line element
and then you can you can introduce a a
scalar variable that parameterizes that
action
and then you can vary the path with
respect to that scalar variable and via
the principle of least action you end up
with
with the the relativistic gdc equation
and so
uh one of the predictions that makes it
if this proof is correct uh
we we you know we can test it because we
know that if the proof is correct
um it will imply that not only are the i
the vacuuming stem field equation
satisfied but the relativistic geodesic
equation should be satisfied
in the continuum limit and that's
exactly what we see so if you just have
a you know if you have a flat
uh sort of a a a a very simple grid-like
hypergraph or a grid-like causal network
and you try to construct gd6
what you get are unsurprisingly uh gd6
that that are
uh essentially more like manhattan
distances than like euclidean distances
but as soon as you have a hypograph
that's sufficiently ergodic as to
justify the
the einstein equation derivation then
suddenly the the combinatorial gd6 that
are defined in terms of the shortest
graph
the shortest path distance between two
points in the hypergraph
become identical to the to the sort of
uh to the extremization gd6
that you would consider in the context
of the relativistic gdc equation
which is a a way that we can kind of
empirically validate that in fact yes
the einstein field equations are being
satisfied
in the in the infinite limit okay
but that's all quite exciting uh but you
you might be thinking well the vacuum
einstein field equations aren't the
whole story because our universe doesn't
just contain vacuum it also contains
matter
and kind of the place where the
eyeshadow field equations get genuinely
interesting
is where you have coupling between
matter and gravitational fields that's a
good point so of course we need we need
to have some notion of an energy
momentum tensor if
we're going to be able to handle that so
i kind of touched on this very briefly
yesterday but
this is an opportunity to go into it in
a bit more detail but um
essentially our minimal model for what
kind of baryonic matter corresponds to
in the context of these models
is essentially a local a persistent and
localized topological obstruction in the
hypograph so yesterday i gave the
example
of uh of sort of non-planar subgraphs
that
propagate in an otherwise planar network
um
but there are actually many many more
sort of instances of topological
obstructions that you could consider
in fact there's this there's this rather
deep theorem in combinatorics which is
the seymour robertson theorem that
allows you that's basically a grand
generalization of kurotovsky's theorem
and vagueness theorem
in in graph theory that allows you to
have a complete classification of
topological obstructions
in in the context of ordinary graphs and
actually we i've worked a little bit on
constructing generalizations of it that
also apply in the hypergraph case
and effectively what it says is that you
you know for every for every top for
every class of topological obstructions
there is an associated graph family
that's preserved under the operation of
taking minors
um that's something i may discuss a bit
more in the quantum mechanics lectures
if i have time but
um anyway that's sort of that's a slight
aside the the point is
as long as we have a notion of a
persistent localized topological
obstruction
we can we can have some notion of a
particle like excitation in the context
of one of these hydrographs
and those particle particle-like
excitations will also appear in the
causal network as we'll see in a second
so here's a kind of minimal example of
that here's a hypergraph transformation
rule
here that produces this little kind of
protuberance that appears in the
hypograph
and that protuberance kind of propagates
around and it kind of i mean it waves
around and it oscillates but it but it
remains persistent because
the the initial topological obstruction
that's introduced by the initial
condition
is always preserved by this particular
choice of rules so
that's kind of our minimal model of what
a baryonic matter particle is
so if we look it's so this is the this
is the the sequence of space
uh spatial hypographs that the sequence
of space like hypersurfaces
if we look at the overall causal network
we can see the signature of the presence
of that topological obstruction
effectively of that particle of baryonic
matter
okay so what does that have to do with
anything so
um now in what we were doing before
uh when we were doing these dimension
and curvature estimates for causal
networks and hypergraphs
we were kind of assuming that the thing
was was homogeneous and isotropic right
we were assuming that
it kind of didn't matter which direction
we oriented the the causal cone in or
what place in the network we we
we constructed the uh the finite
geodesic ball
but if you have the presence of a
topological topological obstruction
that assumption is no longer true
because now uh in the in the presence of
one of these topological obstructions
the local connectivity of the network is
much higher than in the background space
and so in your so your dimension and
curvature calculations
effectively have to accommodate not just
for the for the natural kind of
homogeneous background space
but they also have to accommodate for
the density of these topological
obstructions
that effectively the the density of
baryonic matter contributions
so uh when we when we add that in you
know the relativistic lagrangian density
that appeared in our calculation of the
global dimension anomaly
if we're adding in a term that's
proportional to the to the to the
density to the density of these
topological obstructions
we're just adding we're just adding in
some term lm for a constant
cm that is the sort of coupling term so
effectively in the continuum limit
it's it's introducing a matter field
term to our relativistic lagrangian
density
okay now the significance of that is
that again this is something i kind of i
briefly touched on yesterday
if we if we interpret so you know the
standard in relativity the standard
interpretation for the
for for the energy momentum tensor t mu
nu in upper index form
is it's the it's the flux of
relativistic formament and pmu
through a hyper through a hypersurface
of constant x-nu in the in space-time
and so in the causal network we can
derive we can define that as being the
flux of causal edges
which is our analog relativistic form
momentum through a
through an arbitrary hypersurface in the
causal network so if that hypersurface
is space-like
you get the energy contribution if the
hypersurface is time-like
you get the momentum contribution and
somewhere in between you get some other
projection of the of the energy momentum
tensor
so uh in other words uh we and what that
means is we can we can take the energy
momentum tensor and just like we do in
ordinary relativity
we can divide it up into a vacuum piece
and a baryonic matter piece right we can
divide it up into the energy momentum
associated with the maintenance of the
background space
and the energy momentum associated with
the propagation of topological
obstructions
where and the propagand and the energy
momentum associated with the propagation
of topological obstructions
adds additional connectivity to the
causal network that goes beyond
the connectivity you'd expect just from
the vacuum and that's why you know so
that's essentially why we're adding in
this
this
matter field term so then uh
assuming a a the sort of standard
relativistic equation of state for these
topological obstructions so in other
words assuming that they
that they satisfy the same equation of
state as baryonic matter satisfies
in our universe which obviously we don't
know we suspect it's true but
we until we actually know what
elementary particles look like
in causal networks we won't know for
certain whether they do actually obey
this equation of state
um but this is kind of the standard the
standard equation of state assumption
they get
that gets made in ordinary relativity
and in cosmology and so as long as
that's true
and you know i should mention obviously
we're not claiming that actual particles
are are this straightforward we you know
we we really don't know what an actual
topic
the the actual topological obstructions
that correspond to things like neutrinos
or electrons or whatever
are probably much more complicated than
this and we don't know how to classify
them yet
that's we're hoping someone might be
able to do a project on that actually
in the next few weeks um but so
anyway assuming those topological
obstructions uh have the standard
equation of state form
that they do in ordinary general
relativity in terms of this effective
matter action so
we're dividing up the the relativistic
lagrangian density into the
into the vacuum piece which is
associated with the background hypograph
and the effective matter action that is
the the contribution to the dimension
curvature calculation
that's due to the presence of the
baryonic matter then as long as those
assumptions are valid
if we then run through the argument
again we minimize the combined action
that inc incorporates the vacuum
contribution
and the uh and the the the matter
density contribution
then we obtain the full uh non-vacuum
einstein field equations with this eight
pi ta
tab or tmu quantity on the right hand
side
um so that's that's how we go about
deriving kind of full full general
relativity
um you may have noticed we kind of
imposed an explicit violation of the
equivalence principle here right
we assumed that it wasn't possible um
you know or the ordinary equivalence
principle says somehow that all forms of
energy are in some way equivalent
that's one way you can think about what
the equivalence principle means and so
in particular vacuum energy
and baryonic matter energy shouldn't be
distinguishable uh here we're kind of
assuming that they are
because what we want to be able to do is
we of course we could just put
everything into the energy momentum
tensor but in order to make actual
correspondence with ordinary
relativity and ordinary cosmology we
want to be able to separate the energy
momentum terms that are due to the
presence of matter
and the cosmological constant terms that
are due to the presence of vacuum and so
that's what we can
answer but by making this separation by
effectively explicitly
uh distinguishing between those two
forms of energy that's something we can
do
uh but it's worth noting that you know
straight out of the box
there's no reason to do that right a
causal edge is a causal edge a causal
edge doesn't care
whether it's associated with the
maintenance of the background space or
associated with the propagation of a
particle
and so uh in in in the most fundamental
form
uh the the sort of model derivation of
general relativity is perfectly
compatible with the equivalence
principle
but but but in order to make
correspondence with ordinary
relativistic formalism we actually have
to explicitly break the equivalence
principle and make this separation which
is kind of an
irony that somehow uh th this derivation
is somehow
even more correct than the ordinary
relativistic derivation
um i'm aware that i'm running out of
time so i uh yeah okay i'll just go
through these last two slides and then
we have a slightly longer slot um this
afternoon so i'll i'll try to get
there's a lot of more stuff i want to
talk to to talk to you about about
relations to
fluid dynamics and about implications
for cosmology but let's not
rush things and try to get through all
of those in this lecture i'll save those
for this afternoon
so the the one thing i want to mention
is just following up on that equivalence
principle point
um you know we're we're distinguishing
between the density of causal ledgers
involved in maintaining space
and the density of causal edges involved
in in propagating these particles but
there's no reason to do that
and again we can see explicitly that the
equivalence principle is satisfied
and the wolfram model is is is
compatible with non-zero values of the
cosmological constant
by simply noting that uh this derivation
only defines the einstein field
equations up to an integration constant
because back here
when we defined this global global
dimension anomaly quantity
which we then extremized if we added on
some some additive constant here
it wouldn't make any difference the
externalization would work through
exactly the same exercising something
with an additive constant is the same
as externalizing it without the constant
there so if we
add in a rather suggestive term of a of
like a two lambda term that so some as
i'm arbitrary additive constant which we
can think of as being like
the integration constant that gets
introduced when we do this this
externalization
we we get a relativistic lagrangian
density with a two lambda term appearing
and the extremization is exactly the
same but now we get a
a lambda gab term appearing on the
left-hand side of the equations so in
other words we
we can indeed prove formally that by
making this explicit separation this
explicit violation of the equivalence
principle
and separating the flux of causal edges
associated with the maintenance of space
and the flux of causal edges associated
with the propagation of particles
but by by doing that separation uh we we
obtain a effectively a an integration
constant quantity
that is exactly that has exactly the
form of the cosmological constant
quantity
in ordinary sort of inordinate
relativity and ordinary cosmology
so uh and and this uh i i will talk in
uh
later when we do a follow-up to this
lecture and i go into a bit more detail
detail about the cosmological
consequences of that uh the
the the precise nature of this
derivation uh does have sort of
fairly in my opinion fairly interesting
implications for things like the dark
energy and cosmological constant
problems that arise effectively from the
fact that we have this freedom to do a
separation between vacuum energy
and and baryonic matter energy but uh
let me not
let me not get distracted by talking
about that now and we'll we'll discuss
that later on
uh this afternoon okay how am i doing
for time i'm
right on time that's amazing okay i was
not expecting that
uh okay so shall we i guess uh aaron
isn't here so
i i guess you know we should shift over
to the other discussion room
um one thing i want to mention is i i'd
like to apologize yesterday we
basically in in the discussion session
afterwards we kind of had like an open q
a
and the more i think about it the more i
realized that was an incredibly stupid
idea
and so so what i what i'm going to do
this time hopefully if i can figure out
how to use zoom
is when we go over and do the group
discussion in a minute i'm going to set
up some some breakup rooms hopefully we
have some tas and mentors and people
there
who are available to help us man those
breakout rooms and we'll try to put
maybe five or ten
students in each breakout room depending
on how many mentors we have and
i'll kind of float around between those
breakup rooms and hopefully it'll be a
little bit
less daunting to speak in a group of
five or ten people than it would be to
speak in a group of like 60 people
um and so so then uh if you have
questions or concerns or
other things or you know things you
disagree with or things you want to
discuss in relation to yesterday's
lecture or today's lecture or whatever
then then we can raise them in the
discussion group and hopefully we can
get some some interesting conversations
going
so unless anyone has any immediate
questions they want to ask or any
concerns
uh let's we can shift over to the other
room i forget which one it is
and i will see you guys on the other
side